when you demoralize the police because
defunding the police happens in a in a
in a fiscal year right so if you talk
about defunding now you have to wait to
the next budget then to cut the budget
um so they may not
have the effects of the defunding until
the next fiscal year however when you
mention it you start to demoralize the
police department you start to create
rhetoric and in the uh morale of the
police department begin to crumble
police begin to or they eliminate
proactive policing which is one of the
main key of policing to help the
community and to stop crime is being
proactive they stay they that
perspective of policing begins to go
away
good officers with training and
experience and leadership leave the
police department through retirement and
then you have young people coming up
with no guidance young people coming up
lost in the police department and then
if you don't pay them well the people
who are good and they'll get another job
then you're going to be stuck with
people who may not not everybody but may
not be as qualified and then you have
unqualified police without proper
training in finance
one of the things that i find
interesting about this is there's a
certain obsession with the trials an
obsession with all the minutia of what
happened and i think what you said a
moment ago is right it's like you guys
have to make snap decisions it doesn't
mean all the decisions are right but
then months later you got lawyers and
judges and trial experts and everybody
looking at everything with a microscope
and it's like that's not exactly how it
all happens in real life yeah i mean you
gotta think of this you know some people
have probably experienced a dramatic
situation where they feel um a sprayed
or a tense situation where sometimes
they feel like they froze or they had
tunnel vision or they didn't know what's
going on they're shaking the adrenaline
is rushing you gotta imagine
the police officers are experiencing
what you are experiencing but then have
to make a decision whether to kill
somebody or not or whether to you know
do different arrests or chase or in a
split second and then after the fact
people monday morning quarterback and
say you know i wouldn't have done that
you shouldn't have shot that person but
it's like the same fear that you feel
from somebody knocking on your door whom
you don't know who it is you know which
is nowhere near the fear of a man
pulling a gun out on you or you think
he's putting a gun out on you
i just wish that people could have a
glimpse in into policing where they
could say okay i understand i may not
agree the cop may be wrong but at least
i'm coming from a standpoint and saying
i understand the stress i understand
what these officers may go through there
may be another side of this that i may
need to consider before making a a
formal conclusion so
the goal is not to convince or brainwash
anybody into anything but to say there's
another side of this that you may want
to be privy to so you can make an
educated opinion about things that go on
in law enforcement you talk about the
media a lot of the book obviously i mean
is that problem that you're laying out
right there is that purely on the media
or should the police departments be
doing something different should the you
know local the mayors the governors like
where does that really fall when when
you have that disconnect between what's
really going on and then what we see
i think there's blame to go around in
all aspects you know law enforcement you
know i would like to consider them to
hold themselves accountable as well and
that we need to work on our messaging we
need to work on being more involved in
the community we need to recruit
individuals from the community to be a
part of the police department so the
police department has an objective you
know the leaders
local government they have an objective
as well i mean they need to push and
promote and support the joining together
of the community and police and also
parents people who are in the community
it's not just the police officers you
need to raise your children in a way in
which you're not demonizing law
enforcement before they ever have an
interaction
why can't you go out as a community
leader and say look we want to be more
involved in the community we want to do
ride-alongs
everybody together should work in a
sense to to make sure that that
connection happens um it's i don't
believe it's just one side or the other
i think everybody has to come together
and then we can see a better more
equitable relationship between law
enforcement and the community right that
was equitable in a good sense not the
way that the word is usually used how
worried are you how worried are you that
um that basically what has happened now
in the democrat cities in the
progressive cities is they've demonized
the police to such a point and defunded
the police to such a point that not only
are you going to get less qualified
people but that the the breakdown is
just too severe sort of like in
minneapolis ilhan omer she defunded the
police
and then when people saw a crime spike
and murder spike and everything else
what'd she do she blamed the police for
not doing their job because there
weren't enough of them i mean it's
extraordinary you got to kind of admire
the evil
yeah i mean these people are i think
that they are not acting in good faith
right i believe they push rhetoric that
they think could be trendy enough to get
them elected but it doesn't have real
life application and in many cases they
would love to see things get destroyed
so they can be the the focus of change
you know it's like no you created the
problem now you want to be the solution
to the problem you know and i think that
that's where they're coming from the
citizens are experiencing this i mean
when you demoralize the police because
defunding the police happens in
in a fiscal year right so if you talk
about defunding now you have to wait to
the next budget then to cut the budget
um so they may not
have the effects of the defunding until
the next fiscal year however when you
mention it you start to demoralize the
police department you start to create
rhetoric and in the uh morale of the
police department begin to crumble
police begin to to or they eliminate
proactive policing which is one of the
main key of policing to help the
community and to stop crime is being
proactive they stay they that
perspective of policing begins to go
away
good officers with training and
experience and leadership leave the
police department through retirement and
then you have young people coming up
with no guidance young people coming up
lost in the police department and then
if you don't pay them well the people
who are good and they'll get another job
then you're going to be stuck with
people who
may not not everybody but may not be as
qualified and then you have unqualified
police without proper training in
finance so
i really wish
that that people would take a step back
and look at it and say what are the
complaints of law enforcement okay they
need better training okay we need more
funding so that we can train officers
recruit better officers that takes more
money not less money now you can
reallocate funds
um if you feel like there's wasteful
spending but to completely be mon you
know the i would say uh
defund i was gonna say devalue
demonetized but but defundable will be
demonetized we know that right right
i'm so used to that word demonetization
so you know to you know to defund the
police is
it's not it's not a winning strategy and
the crime rate has has spoken on that
behalf
do you see any hope in that regard that
as we've seen these cities defund i mean
seattle did a major defund push we got
chop crime went crazy murders i think
something like six up 600 percent but
now suddenly they're saying okay maybe
we're not going to fully defund or the
mayor of even crazy portland who you
know got heckled out of his own
apartment had to leave because of
protesters and move suddenly he's moving
a little against it do you see some hope
in some of these places
yeah i think that things ebb and flow
you know you're going to have uh police
becoming excellent and then you're going
to have times where they hate the police
and and i think that we're experiencing
that now because it's a mathematical
equation it's very simple there's no way
to evade it if you defund the police you
lose police officers then you cannot
have a adequate amount of people to to
push law and order and so people are
gonna do crimes and here's the here's
another thing
in addition to defunding the police and
demoralizing police when you have the
prosecutors
not even prosecuting people on crimes
especially in places like california and
different places where you can steal 900
worth of stuff and you're not going to
be prosecuted when you couple that with
defunding the police i mean you a city
cannot exist a city cannot stand small
businesses cannot live even major
corporations have the financial support
to leave a city and then you have an
economic structure that's that's you
know down tried and destroyed in some of
these cities where you see the
proliferation of violence and
proliferation of theft i mean we see it
all over the country now people are just
bomb rushing these places stealing
hundreds of thousands of millions of
dollars worth of property
it can only go on so long before people
begin to say okay enough is enough
there's no way we can survive this you
know people are dying every day in the
streets i i come outside i used to be
able to have my car
to park it on the street now it's
getting vandalized people taking my my
property i don't feel safe um when when
that begins to happen you see the
character of people voting you see that
begin to change if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell